les uns après les autres ils arrivent au
bourget rafale marine française
f 15 américain black stallion chargés de
la récupération des pilotes tombé en
territoire ennemi
chine 96b et l'incroyable belga l'avion
le volumineux gronde france à 24 heures
de l'ouverture au public le bourges
accueille les équipages venus
apparemment avec de quoi se changer
avant de partir visiter paris auto
express que vous espérez de
répondre voulait rendre
tous tous élite je ne peux rien vous
dire on fait aussi des rencontres
surprenantes au bourget
et juin 89
crash historique
et cette année encore il est là alain
tony corse crurent bien vivant et en
pleine forme
do you remember votre
assureur qui 16
ce soir tous les avions sont arrivés on
passe
arriveront le boeing
777 et surtout le bombardier stratégique
furtifs américains b2 il devait rester
toute la semaine le pentagone a réduit
sa présence à seulement une petite heure
il faudra faire vite pour le voir le b2
mérite bien sa réputation d'avions
furtifs